CLAYTON BRIGSBY, BLACK WHITE
SUPREMACIST
VENTURED OUT
INTO AN UNSUSPECTING WORLD.
SIR, YOU'RE A FRIEND.
WHY NOT TELL HIM HE'S
AFRICAN-AMERICAN ?
LISTEN, MAN, HE'S TOO
IMPORTANT TO THE MOVEMENT.
IF I TELL HIM HE'S BLACK,
HE'D PROBABLY KILL HISSELF
JUST SO THERE'D BE ONE LESS
NIGGER AROUND.
HIS COMMITMENT IS THAT DEEP.
I'M OVERWHELMED
BY THE IRONY.
( banging )
UH-OH.
( man )
WHAT, YOU LOST, BOY ?
MOVE ON, MOVE ON.
WE DON'T LIKE YOUR KIND
AROUND HERE !
YOU BETTER GET OUT OF HERE
'FORE SOMETHING BAD HAPPENS.
THAT'S RIGHT,
THAT'S RIGHT !
TELL THAT NIGGER !
BEAT IT,
YOU SORRY NIGGER !
COME ON, CLAYTON,
WE GOTTA GO.
OH, JASPER, THERE'S
A NIGGER AROUND HERE.
THAT DAMN MONKEY WAS
BEATIN' MY HOOD !
WHITE POWER !
NIGGER--
THE CONFUSION
DID NOT END THERE.
( hip-hop music )
HEY, WHY DON'T YOU JUNGLE
BUNNIES TURN THAT MUSIC DOWN ?!
NIGRAS MAKE ME SICK !
WOOGIE-BOOGIE,
NIGGER !
WOOGIE-BOOGIE !
DID HE JUST CALL US
"NIGGERS" ?
AWESOME !
THE ANTICIPATION WAS AT
A FEVER PITCH
AS WE ARRIVED AT
MR. BIGSBY'S BOOK SIGNING.
THIS IS THE MAN
WHO SHOULD BE
THE NEXT PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES !
( cheering )
ALL RIGHT, JASPER,
TIME TO SHOW THESE PEOPLE
WHAT WHITE POWER'S
ALL ABOUT.
YOU BETTER PUT
YOUR HOOD ON, CLAYTON,
MIGHT WANNA HIDE
YOUR IDENTITY.
IT'D BE SAFER,
IN CASE SOME RADICAL
AIN'T SYMPATHETIC TO THE CAUSE
AND WANTS TO SHOOT YOU.
THAT'S GOOD THINKING,
ALL RIGHT.
I'M GONNA
PUT MY HOOD ON.
HERE, LET ME GET THAT.
( man )
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO,
THE MAN
WHO MADE US
PROUD TO BE WHITE,
NONE OTHER THAN,
CLAYTON BIGSBY !
LET'S HEAR IT !
( cheers & applause )
WHITE POWER !
EVERYBODY, I HAVE
A LOT OF THINGS TO DISCUSS,
MAINLY NIGRAS.
AMERICA'S AT WAR
WITH AL QAEDA,
BUT WE'RE STILL LOSING THE WAR
AGAINST AL SHARPTON !
( host )
THE ASIAN COMMUNITY
WAS A TARGET AS WELL.
LET'S TALK ABOUT
CHINESE PEOPLE,
WITH THEIR KUNG FU
AND ALL THAT SILLY
"CHING CHANG CHONG" TALK.
I CAN'T UNDERSTAND YOU,
GO BACK TO YOUR COUNTRY.
WHITE POWER.
MR. BIGSBY WAS ALSO CRITICAL
OF THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY.
DON'T LET THE LIBERAL MEDIA
TELL YOU HOW TO THINK AND FEEL.
IF YOU HAVE HATE IN YOUR HEART,
LET IT OUT.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE
WILL & GRACE,
THAT DON'T MEAN THERE'S
SOMETHING WRONG WITH YOU.
IT MEANS THERE'S SOMETHING
WRONG WITH WILL !
HE'S A HOMOSEXUAL.
POLITICIANS
WEREN'T SPARED EITHER.
WHITE POWER !
COLIN POWELL...
"CUNNILINGUS" RICE.
"CUNNILINGUS" RICE
SOUNDS LIKE A MEXICAN DISH,
MAYBE WE SHOULD PUT HER ON
A PLATE AND SEND HER TO MEXICO
SO THE MEXICANS WILL EAT HER--
WHITE POWER.
WHITE POWER !
JUST OPEN UP YOUR HEART
AND LET THAT HATE OUT !
( cheers & applause )
SHOW US YOUR FACE,
WE WANNA SEE YOUR FACE !
WHO SAID THAT,
YOU WANNA SEE MY FACE ?
CLAYTON,
GO ON, BROTHER.
DO YOU WANNA
SEE MY FACE ?
DON'T BE AFRAID, JASPER.
( hollering )
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS--
DON'T BE AFRAID,
SHINE YOUR LIGHT !
THERE IS COOKIE AND PUNCH
FOR US TO ENJOY,
AND WE CAN MEET,
TALK ABOUT WHITE BROTHERHOOD.
THANK Y'ALL FOR COMING,
WHITE POWER !
MR. BIGSBY WAS NOT HARMED
THAT NIGHT,
BUT IRREPARABLE DAMAGE HAS
BEEN DONE TO HIS REPUTATION
AND, IN MANY WAYS,
TO THE WHITE-POWER MOVEMENT.
WE'RE TOLD THAT
IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS,
HE HAS ACCEPTED THE FACT
THAT HE IS A BLACK MAN.
AND THREE DAYS AGO,
HE FILED FOR DIVORCE
FROM HIS WIFE.
WHEN WE ASKED, "WHY,
AFTER 19 YEARS OF MARRIAGE ?"
HE RESPONDED:
"BECAUSE SHE'S
A NIGGER LOVER."
I'M KENT WALLACE,
GOOD NIGHT.
( man )
FUNDING FOR "FRONTLINE"
PROVIDED BY
THE "TRENT LOTT FOUNDATION"
FOR PEACE AND UNDERSTANDING.
LOVING BLACK PEOPLE,
ONE AT A TIME.